and welcome everyone
to our program preview
what you should enroll in the data
science job guarantee program from
Simply learn
I have with me today
vinay Bohr who's the product and manager
for
uh the job guarantee programs and also
shubham Pandi who is
one of our senior data science
instructors they're both on mute right
now but they cannot mute themselves
and my name is Stuart Creek I am
uh marketing manager here at simply
learn
we want to share with you this very
exciting program
um
we're going to start by talking about
data science careers which is why you're
all here you're all interested in
launching a data science career and
we'll talk about
then what this particular program offers
you and how it gets you job ready via
will describe how the job guarantee
works
and two of them will take us through the
program curriculum
and we'll talk about the steps that you
need to take to enroll
putting the prerequisites and the
requirements and then we'll take your
questions
so let's begin
and um I'm introducing here is 11 years
of experience he's one of our most noted
data science instructors in our program
um
as particular expertise
and
strategy Consulting in the marketing
domain so I
well equipped to talk about data science
and how it's applied in industry
and we'll talk about
how data drives the economy
we have noticed all of us all of you out
there in the last couple of years since
the onset of the covid pant pandemic
that
much of what we used to do in person
we've had to do online there's been a
huge shift a huge digital transformation
and that just accelerated a trend that
has been going on for many years
um
we've seen more and more of Our Lives
moving into the digital domain creating
data with every touch point
and that means that the companies that
provide us with Business Services
through these digital media
need to understand what that data is
telling them one of my favorite examples
is from an American fast food chain
called Wendy's which very famously
launched its online ordering app
so that people would be able to order
their food before going to the
restaurant to pick it up at the
drive-through window
what they found out from doing this is
that they were gathering incredible
amounts of data about customer
preferences and behaviors
and so they served mining that data and
using it to shape their marketing
efforts their advertising
um even their operations so
something as mundane as a restaurant
chain
now living in the digital world and
looking for people who can't help them
analyze and draw insights from that data
um
the data has grown vastly and
projection a couple years ago was that
it would reach 175 the zettabytes in
2025 but
um that's just accelerated so that
number is probably out of date at this
point and
depending on Big Data is just
mushrooming so
companies really need talent in this
area and they need people who can help
them
turn that sea of data into actionable
insights and projections and
prescriptions
philbum what has been your experience in
working with uh companies in the
industry
advice to alerted everybody
uh
as a start you mentioned very lightly
here that
we have huge demand of resources here
still we have a big gap in demand and
Supply because
data explosion age we are living in and
the kind of tools we have and the kind
of algorithms we have we have great
capability to mine that data and come up
with great insights but we don't have
resources to fulfill the requirements so
a lot of scope in this particular
industry I believe
okay thank you
yeah and and the number of different
roles and career paths available to you
when you embark on a data science career
or myriad
of course you can move up to the level
of data scientist if you are interested
in um
getting deeper into both Theory and
application and designing
solutions to data problems uh you can
work as a data analyst who applies those
Solutions on a day-to-day basis and
turns data into insights uh you can be
an engineer or an architect who looks at
how the data itself is structured
managed and conditioned
um
could be a database administrator
you become a machine learning engineer
because one of the main uses of data is
to feed it into
Ai and machine Learning Systems so that
they can draw the insights directly and
automatically you can become a business
intelligence developer analyst
Specializes
the application of data to business
problems and presenting that in ways
that are accessible and understandable
to executives
um and you of course you can become a
statistician and look at
mathematical properties of data and
relationships in the data
so all of these roles are available to
you these are paths that you can take
from the fundamental start but you need
a foundation
um
and the broader
basic Foundation the better you're
prepared to take on any of those roles
understanding the various skills that
you see in the icons at the right
and especially things like machine
learning understanding Big Data what
that means and how to administer and use
it data warehouses data Lakes which are
techniques for
managing Big Data the statistics and of
course the visualization because the
ultimate purpose of
data science and data analysis is to
turn
the insights that you pull from the data
into something that people can
understand and use in their day-to-day
activities so it's important to be able
to translate that and tell the story of
the data
so
we asked the question and I'm going to
launch this whole question for the
people watching
coming through WebEx but if you are on
our live stream
uh
the
oh
here we go
if you're on the live stream on YouTube
you can definitely take a look at that
and put that into the comments
okay
and
if you'll give me a moment I need to
take care of one quick administrative
thing here
I don't have a few more seconds to get
your answers in
all right and I'll share the answers
with you now
and so the the most common answer among
this group
is that you don't feel you have
um you can't find a program that will
give you
the uh
fundamental experience that you can
demonstrate
to prospective employers
and that's a important concern and then
the other concerns
all come in about a quarter to a third
of the audience about
the
moment
about whether you have time
all right and
it's very strange
okay
apologize for that little side
Adventure there but let's move on
but let's talk about the
data science job guarantee partner
and the program
duration is six months it's all
delivered online
comprehensive curriculum which
of them will be describing
and
it continues to uh with integrated Labs
with Hands-On projects things that you
do directly on the learning platform
so you don't have to go from one system
to another to do your work it's all done
in one integrated
learning management system that includes
online live virtual classrooms with
instructors like show them where you'll
meet generally every weekend and
take those classes live and then in the
middle of the week you can do your
projects and other work at any time 24 7
that's convenient for you which is why
we call it flexible
and you get a guaranteed job offer on
completion which I mean we'll talk about
so let's
talk about the result
when you complete the program you have a
certificate that shows that you have
achieved
and completed all of the core classes
within the curriculum and demonstrated
your capability
you've demonstrated that my classroom
attendance but you've also demonstrated
that by successfully completing over 30
different projects and integrated labs
and then completing a Capstone project
which is a final project for the entire
course for the entire program
that integrates all of the different
skills and tools that you have learned
six months
done under the supervision of one of
your instructors
and it is something that goes into your
portfolio that you can show to people
that says this is how I solved
an industry based
real world type problem this is the
solution I built
data science domain
with that and with the other support
that we give you you will receive within
six months of completing the program a
guaranteed job offer and I will let
Bene speak about
what that means
hello and good evening everyone
um I'll teach you about
Job guarantee and the eligibility
criteria for uh anyone to enroll for
this job guarantee program
so
um as uh your Avail this is the job
guarantee program uh once you complete
the program uh in a six months period of
time and you unlock the certificate
uh you will get a job within six months
uh post completion of the program
and if you don't get a job which is our
uh simple and promise you will get 100
of your fees refund
right so it's a guaranteed job or a
hundred percent refund if you don't get
a job after completion of the program
provided you have uh completed all the
lessons uh on self learning the live
classes Capstone projects and other
projects that we are conducting
throughout the program
uh what are the job guarantee benefits
um post completion of the program uh you
will get uh our job search support for a
period of six months so six months of
the program six months of your career
services period within which we will
support you to find the relevant job in
the data science field
we will help you with building your
resume Career Mentoring interview
preparation which are required for you
to crack any type of an interview
uh we will also give you the job of a
job board access uh so we we actually we
have a job board where we put uh all the
job requirements uh which are there in
the market so that you can come uh apply
for the different type of companies that
we have partnered with and uh put your
resume uh as per your interest and get
selected uh you know your dream job
uh in order uh to be eligible for this
to enroll for this program uh you should
need the required eligibility criteria
which I'll box you through in an
upcoming slide including work
eligibility uh before you enroll uh to
the program you will have to pass one
entrance assessment test once you come
complete and pass the test you will get
access to the program
once you get access to the program you
are a period of six months uh the
program period will start once you
complete the program uh you'll get the
job opportunity we did a six minutes of
period of time
so what are the eligibility criteria uh
for any learner to get into this field
uh we should have basic understanding of
programming Concepts and Mathematics not
very deep understanding required uh any
basic type of understanding which would
be sufficient to get started with
uh you should have any of the decrease
that we have mentioned here we take and
take DCA MCA bscit mscit or MBA degree
you must hold one of the one of these
degree uh you must have you you should
complete uh these degrees
uh before joining or at the time of few
pass out from this program and you
should have 60 percent academic record
throughout your 10th 12th graduation and
in case if you have done your post
graduation you should have 60 minimum 60
marks throughout your academic and you
should be uh
graduate of 2017 and onwards which
basically means uh you should have zero
to five years of work experience when
you graduate from this program
which includes six months period of your
learning uh in the data science program
uh before you enroll for this program
you should have current uh CPC less than
4 lakhs per annum uh in Indian currency
at the time of your enrollment of the
program these are the eligibility
criteria which all others should fulfill
and then you get enrolled into this
program
thank you vinay and what I'm going to do
is uh ask this question of the audience
here
relating to the the requirements
how many years of experience do you
currently have
in the workplace
which includes all experience not just
data science
give you another 10 seconds to answer
the question
there we go
so two-thirds of our audience are in
that category of zero to five years of
experience
we have some folks with a bit more
experience
um
and it would
be a question of what
field you're in and whether you're
looking to switch Fields but
um
generally the folks in these zero to
five year category are the
uh intended target for this program so
let's move on
I'll talk about how the program prepares
you and at this point
I'm going to uh
but
show them take over and share his screen
he'll share with you these points about
the curriculum and
how the learning management system works
so
give me just a moment here
and show them there you are
and we see yours we see your screen
and you can hear me as well yeah
so everybody uh this is
the LMS learning management system it's
a One-Stop shop for you for all your
learning needs
am I not Audible
oh [ __ ] I think you are um
yes I'm sorry about that
um yeah we can hear you uh your voice is
a little bit faint but uh
we can understand you
okay is it better
my voice is better now
yes great so this is the learning
management system this is LMS and this
is a One-Stop shop for you for all your
learning needs
here on this LMS you'll be able to see
all your courses
here on this LMS you'll be able to find
all the self-paced videos all the course
content apart from that you'll also get
here uh community on which you can
interact with your colleagues so I'll
take you through uh the LMS so here you
can see this program data science job
guarantee program
so for data science
basically you need the basic knowledge
of mathematics and more than that you
should have appetite to learn
so for mathematics
you have here statistics essential for
data science
and then some basic tools like Excel
like SQL
these two tools are very essential
whatever work you are doing in data
science field you will get to use SQL
for sure you'll get to use Excel for
sure so you should be good at Excel and
SQL so these initial courses will
actually prepare for the advanced
courses which are in line after SQL and
Excel so statistics then business
analytics with Excel then you've got SQL
and then after that uh Here Comes data
science with python
so I'll just take you through this
course I'll just open it I'll click on
this and here you go
you can see here
on the left hand side panel you've got
these options self learning live classes
uh practice Labs assessments and then
certificates in safe learning you will
find here all the self-paced videos so
before you come to the live session
you are required to go through these
self-paced videos to be ready for the
discussion because all the sessions are
Hands-On and all the sessions are very
interactive so you should participate in
the discussion you should share your
thoughts your ideas your questions in
the class and for that to happen
effectively you should go through these
self-paced videos apart from that you've
got here course resources I hear you got
ebooks and the data which is required
then using this live classes tab you can
join your classes you can also look into
the recordings of the previous sessions
since all these classes of weaveless
seamlessly weave together so it is
always advised not to miss any session
in the middle but if you miss any
session because of some unavoidable
circumstances you better go through the
cell better go through the self-paced
videos and
these recordings before you come to the
next session to be able to catch up with
others
then here we've got practice lab as well
in practice lab like here we have just
Jupiter lab to run Python scripts
so this gives you the environment you
will which you will get in your work
it's a cloud-based platform which will
give you a very good exposure of working
in Python
and have got assessments these projects
and you need to walk on any one project
and once you will be able to finish the
projects uh you'll be able to unlock
your certificate so this is about each
program so these this is called as
course and project
so once you will complete any course
you'll have to work on the project part
because it is not only about learning
theories it is not only about learning
programming or for that matter
mathematics it is about marrying
everything all together and solve
problems so basically you need to
develop the problem solving skills and
for that project work is very essential
the same as you'll find for machine
learning part as well and the same you
have for tableau
okay and once you will complete all the
courses the last course here is course 8
which is a Capstone project so Capstone
projects are complex in nature and they
will give you the experience of Walking
in real life projects so here you'll be
given a very complex problem to solve
and the data will you will be given to
you and the data will not be cooked up
data I mean the data will not be
cleaned and all those things will not be
done for you you'll have to start from
scratch and will be given several weeks
to solve that so that will give you a
very good exposure so this is uh about
this course uh and then you have here
community on community you can
uh interact with your colleagues you can
share data sets you can ask questions uh
within your group and you can also
interact with your trainer here as well
so I think I talked to almost about
everything anything I am missing on here
uh no I don't think so other than
um you know if somebody has a doubt or a
blocker that they come up with uh during
the week they can always
message to
our 24 7 support
is that correct absolutely absolutely so
if anybody has any doubt for doubt
clearing in the live virtual classes as
well we gave first 15 to 20 minutes for
Q a so over the weekend you can ask the
trainer you can interact directly with
the trainer but over the week weekdays
time as well if you're working on some
project if you're working on some
question and you come across any
challenge you can always uh
connect with 24 4 across seven uh our
team and there your question will be
resolved as soon as possible within 24
hours
right
all right thank you very much for that
shubham uh and I will go ahead and
re-share my screen but we can continue
the presentation
just want to let everybody know I'm
trying to log all of the questions in
for the Q a which will be coming up
shortly
foreign
so this is the curriculum that um shared
briefly
and it builds up your skills
in data science in a step-by-step
fashion
so that you get the basics first and
then get into more advanced topics
um we start with of course the
orientation session which is basically
as servant described
make some self-faced videos and other
things that will let you know what the
what to expect during the program the
first real course is statistics
Essentials for data science
and then business analytics with Excel
you move into SQL
and that gives you a foundation in
understanding how to manage the data
itself then you're looking to apply data
science with python
um one of the most important programming
languages for data science
the next is the machine learning course
which takes you into topics and
techniques for machine learning
uh Diablo certification because again
the storytelling and the visualization
is uh very important
and as children prescribed the Capstone
project
where several weeks with mentorship of
instructor to solve that industry-based
problem
and
generate something that you'll be able
to do not only use as your final exam
for the program but also as
example to show as you're interviewing
with the different employers we
introduce you to
uh you have the option along the way
oops sorry of taking the electives data
science with r and other
very important programming technique for
data science and deep learning with
tensorflow and Keras
both of the electives are included in
the program costs so they're up at your
option based on your interest in time
availability
pardon my voice for breaking
you'll be exposed along the way to tools
libraries and languages but more than
being exposed to them you'll actually
use them
and be able to claim on your resume
that you have hands-on experience with
these and many other
uh important data science tools so it's
very
very valuable because instead of putting
on keywords onto your resume and hoping
that they get you through the
evaluation process we'll be able to put
genuine skills on your resume so that
when somebody asks you about what did
you do with
Candice how did you apply the numpy
library
you'll be able to answer that question
with confidence
a very important aspect of this program
and as we mentioned there's a number of
different projects you'll work on
over and Beyond the the Capstone
projects along the way you'll be working
on various projects as well so you might
do an e-commerce project or something
Amazon would would require you to do you
might look at uh
Mercedes-Benz and the automotive
manufacturing
um
domain and see how data science can help
them speed up their
production processes uh can look at
telecommunications having to do with
customer service or banking Financial
or health care and how to
manage Health using data science to
predict who is at risk and how best to
manage their conditions
and in retail looking at customer
segmentation and applying this to a
marketing problem so
these are some of the different kinds of
projects that you'll be working on and
learning how to apply data science in
different industry domains
very important because
understanding how the
skills and the theory work in the
practice of a particular domain is
really what getting a job is all about
we return to the subject of captions on
projects because they are all important
in the program they are your uh final
demonstration that you have acquired
mastered all the skills in the program
um they give you the ability to choose
that detailed real life type industry
problem and create your own solution
with that you do have
the support of an instructor to keep you
from going down dead ends or blockers
and
this is again something that goes into
your
portfolio for future
use in your job search so this is a
really valuable part of our program
let's talk a little bit about learner
outcomes I'm going to ask Danae to
comment
on this slide as well because this shows
some of the success rates of the people
who've taken this program
so
like so
many Learners uh since last year have a
well discourse they have completed it
successfully and got the job into one of
the biggest companies in the market like
Accenture Deloitte axis Bank Tech
Mahindra Cap Gemini recognizant and so
many
we have been able to place uh Learners
in the good companies with good salary
hikes depending on what their their
previously salaries were uh and uh we
have approximately 200 plus hiring
partners with us currently which will be
able to uh which through which we will
be able to place all the Learners uh who
complete uh the program within a
stipulated period of time complete the
connection projects and uh you know
Avail this Career Services uh so that's
it from uh the placements and all the
companies that we have
okay
and this is a testimonial you can
actually see this on the course page on
our website along with several others
but aniket
was able to
leverage the program to get himself a 50
salary hike in a new position so this is
the kind of result
that um
people can get through this program and
she saw it's even possible to get uh a
bigger hike let me share with everyone
here the um
link to the program page on our website
and
what you'll be able to do after this uh
is after this session is go there take a
look at the video that Anna get recorded
with us and hear from him directly
So based on what you have heard so far
I'd like to get an idea of
how many of you are interested in
joining the data science job guarantee
program
the
will give you about 20 seconds to answer
the question I know that that's probably
too long but
it was either giving you that much or
half that much so
in just another 10 seconds
all right and
here's the poll result
uh just under 90 88 of the respondents
in our audience
are interested in joining this program
and that is wonderful
so with that in mind I'm going to share
with you the enrollment steps
first
the enrollment process is a simple
three-step process
start by emailing us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
and I will put that into the chat
once you do that you'll constantly our
lending Consultants will contact your
admission counselors will contact you
um as
you may have said there will be an
evaluation
so you'll have to pass that test they
will also evaluate
your academic qualifications work
experience and that type of thing so
that ensures that you meet the
prerequisites for the program
and
with that uh if you pass that review
you'll receive an admission offer via
email
and you'll be able to convert
a couple of people who ask to unmute to
ask a question please type your question
into the chat box and we will capture
that in the Ina just momentarily
um
program schedule the next class sessions
start on 12th November
uh 9th November is the orientation
session so it's coming up
and
the total program fees for this program
uh one lock ninety eight thousand and
four
um
rupees and then
you have the option of zero cost
financing at
6573 a month
um
which of course lasts longer than the
six months of the program so that you
pay off the
pull them out but um
to get information about enrollment as I
mentioned in the chat box I've shared
ask us at simplylearn.net so you would
start there and
hope that you'll enroll with us with
that I'm going to go ahead and open it
up for the questions and answers because
we do have
a number of questions from the audience
so let me
stop fearing screen so you don't stare
at that slide all the time we're
speaking
and I will start
with some of the questions that we've
already queued up
um
so here's a question from a Learner in
Nigeria trauma
um
is curious to know if
this program applies to folks in Nigeria
and what options they might have
otherwise
you know if you could address that
so this program is basically for about
Indian Learners who are residing in
India
so anyone who is not uh residing in
India or not in India will not be able
to unfortunately unfortunately will not
be able to uh enroll for this course
that also addresses uh Jessica's
question about the availability of the
guarantee to Learners outside India the
guarantee again is that you will get a
job from an Indian employer but if you
are outside India and not able to work
in India
um then of course we can't make that
guarantee to you uh we have a couple of
questions from people
uh who are maybe a little bit outside of
the academic area that you described in
the prerequisites
one of them
is a MSC in microbiology
Prima eligible for this program
no unfortunately not
so as we have informed in the
presentation uh anyone who is with we
take and take BCA MCA BSC in 80 MSC in
it and MBA if you are you have a degree
from one of these
qualifications or Springs then you'll be
able to apply all your eligible for this
program anyone outside of this degrees
will unfortunately will not be able to
enable for this program
um that also covers Muhammad's question
he's a bcom graduate
um
so
now hubo asks
are those without programming knowledge
able to join the program
one of the things we mentioned the
prerequisite is that you have to have a
basic understanding of the programming
mathematics required but you do not have
to have extensive experience in it so
there are certainly courses
that simple learn offers including some
of our in our what we call our skill up
program that can get you some of that
basic programming background get you um
basic understanding that you need to
enroll in this program
um
funkatula asks is uh as a Polytechnic
student passed out in 2012
um are they eligible
uh so I'll answer this question in two
parts basically uh one is Polytechnic I
think that it means a diploma and not a
complete engineering degree but if you
want to enroll for this program you must
have a degree whether btec verb Tech or
vscit or BC at least uh diploma
candidates will not be able to apply or
enroll for this program
second is uh we are allowing uh students
or the Learners who have experience
within zero to five years of experience
and from uh 2017 our graduates uh if you
are not a greater if you are a graduate
from before 2017 uh you will be not be
able to enroll for this program
foreign
question from sarab who has a
compensation between four and a five
luck
uh does that make them ineligible
unfortunately yes so we have Set uh the
uh minimum four uh LPA
as the bar if you are having salary
below four likes per annum in Indian
currency uh at the time of enrollment of
the program you will be able to join but
if you have anything above your legs per
annum salary we currently as uh before
and at the time of enrollment of program
uh you will be not be able to
uh enroll for this program
and I should mention that we uh simple
learn does have a number of other
programs that are not structured as
guaranteed programs for people who are
not eligible for this one uh you can
look into some of our other programs uh
sarab has a question which is
how does data science play an important
role in investment banking
uh maybe you can comment on this
sure sure
so any Investment Banking uh you must
have used a cluster banking clustered
investment
uh have you tried that have you heard
about that
where we create cohorts of different
companies
which are similar in nature and do the
investment accordingly create the
investment strategy accordingly
so it is one of the use cases I'm
talking about other than that you'll be
able to do forecasting using time series
using other supervised supervised
learning methods so you'll be able to do
forecasting and then you'll be able to
make better investment strategy so all
that you can do with the help of machine
learning with the help of data science
Does this answer the question
yeah I think that that that's a great
answer that's one example of many of how
uh data science is important in
Investment Banking and indeed in all
aspects of Banking and Financial
Services so that's absolutely portfolio
management is a very important aspect
for Investment Banking and portfolio
management can be done very effectively
with the help of cohort analysis with
the help of forecasting and all thank
you
thank you shabbat is one of our audience
members who curious to know what average
salary
uh you can expect after completing this
program but what are some of the results
we're getting um
so uh average salary uh one can expect
may vary from
Pilots to eight lakhs per annum but as a
part of our data science job guarantee
program
once you complete the program program
and unlock the certificate and start
applying for the jobs so we are giving
the job guarantee with minimum 5 lakhs
per annum from his Implement guarantee
perspective so that you can take as a
simple lines from this
okay
um
yeah
Petron asks is it easy for pressures to
get a job in data science uh his
experiences that
companies aren't interested in taking
care of fears but that's I think one of
the valuable things about this
particular program is that
your status as a fresher isn't
determining Factor the job guarantee is
that correct
yes so
um it's not uh hard and fast food to
have uh to one have a experience before
you uh enroll for this program if you
are a fresher with zero to one or two
years of experience you will be able to
uh get this get entered in this program
uh provided you have a degree which we
have uh put as a eligibility criteria
okay
there are multiple there are many uh job
opportunities in the market who require
who actually demands uh the fresher
candidates
so that is uh the market scenario which
currently have you can take admission
for this okay
uh
free car has a technical support
question because
they had a problem
um
when they received their link to take
the enrollment test
um they had a personal uh conflict
there's schedule and so they need a new
link so I'll pass that on to our
customer service folks
um we wanted to reassure you that that's
half an extra car uh uh
is it possible that a graduating student
can enroll from this program so what
what is the graduation status
have to be for somebody starting
so uh if a learner if you are in our
last year of your engineering or a
graduation
you can take admission in this program
provided that by the time you complete
this program and unlock the certificate
your graduation should get completed
which means if you are taking admission
into this program uh you should complete
you will be able to complete a program
in six months so within six months you
will be issued able to pass from your
degree also
that is the requirement because once you
go ahead and apply for the jobs
companies uh generally ask for your
degree certificate or the final
marksheet of your degrees right so that
is the requirement
so you want to make sure that you time
it so that you have your degree
by the time that you finish this partner
okay
I'm looking to see as we're getting
close to the end of our hour
uh
uh is this master's program Affiliated
to any uh University or IIT
um no this is uh this program is not
affiliated with any of the University or
any college or as such this is simply
learns uh data science job guarantee
program we have not partnered with any
college or universities for those
just to make that clear and
I think uh Sherman can answer this
question if you would please is Harsha
asks will you have a will he end up with
a total grip on the field of data
science will he the
confident
as a data science practitioner after
this program
it's a good question
so as I described to you the structure
of the whole course and this structure
is decided based on the advices of some
experts in the industry so if you will
follow the structure
if you will follow all the uh
instructions given in the class if you
work on all the projects and complete
your projects on time
you will definitely have a great grip on
data science subject because whatever is
being taught in this course that all is
very contemporary whatever is going in
the industry that all is being discussed
in the class
so after this course you will definitely
have a good grip on data science
provided you give your best as well
okay
thank you for that
um
sumia asks
uh
in a leadership position
in a management position
is this type of Technical Training
valuable
is this a type of program that you would
want to take for that kind of
background
and career path
I think uh film if you could
weigh in on that
sure it's a very good question and in
the classes as well this uh these type
of questions come up uh and I always
tell that this course is equally
important for those people who have a
good experience especially those who
have good industry experience once they
gain the optimum knowledge of tools and
techniques they can be the linchpin for
their company they can be indispensable
for their company because they can
directly get into the decision making
position because nowadays decisions are
not made based on gut feelings decisions
are made based on empirically driven
data driven approaches so you will be
able to make better decisions yes you
need to uh you need to be able to gain
the optimum knowledge of tools and
techniques second thing if you don't
understand how to interpret the outcome
of the analysis even if you don't you're
not working on the tool even if you're
not doing the programming if you don't
know how to interpret the results
then I believe you are lagging behind
because it has become a point of parity
it used to be a point of difference at
some point but if you
able to do
they're not able to interpret the
outcome of data science you will be
lagging behind for sure
I would also observe that if you're in a
leadership position if you're in the
ineligible because you have more
experience and a higher salary rate than
the this program allows we have many
other programs that allow you to get
that kind of
background in data science
um and some of them are tailored to data
science for management so those are
other options that simply can help you
with uh generally speaking if you find
that
you're interested in this type of
program but you don't match the
particular requirements of this job
guarantee program as if you need to
subscribed them we do have other
programs that you should look into that
may not carry the job guarantee but will
give you the
training and the technical knowledge
that this program does and will let you
build your career along the other other
Pathways
um
and we're coming up to the end of our
hour so I'm going to go ahead
and
close out the questions there
making sure I don't have any
critical ones
I do apologize if I have not
been able to get to your question as yet
um
I did have one last question that came
in and the question
in fact two related questions
one is how much time is required
out of somebody's schedule
to complete this program
um the
I think
show them if you could answer that how
much how much time realistically does a
learner need to spend each week
in this
classes and and doing their homework
uh sure so first thing
it is definitely a commitment for your
learning so you have to definitely plan
very well every day I believe one and a
half hour to two hours if you're able to
dedicate for your studies that will be
good enough
and then over the weekend you'll have
four hours of session on Saturday and
four hours of session on uh Sunday so I
believe two hours daily if you will give
regularly with discipline I don't think
there'll be any problem to complete your
course uh with confidence with all that
long
okay
and the last question is
um
shitan asks and vinay if you could
answer
a few more details about how the
job guarantee program works Beyond just
providing you access to
a job board what are the other services
that come with that
so we provide uh Career Mentoring
sessions uh Learners
we conduct interview preparations group
interview sessions
mock interviews resume preparation
these kind of services we provide and
also we provide high-risk portal access
wherein uh the iris also conducts few
career services from their side and you
get access to high risk job portal where
different companies uh do Post their job
listings and simply learn also provides
you a job Workwear the curated jobs are
listed for your you can for a references
you can go ahead and apply them apply on
them our Career Services team will hand
over to you uh during the sixth year the
six months after completion of the
program I think uh that that is all okay
I can tell you yeah and it's very
important to have those kinds of
services because
rather than just saying okay you've got
your certificate now go find a job in
this program you get your certificate
but then you say okay now here's steps
we can help you take to prepare for the
job search
um resume preparation is very important
because today resumes go through
AI screening systems and so the ability
to format your resume so that passes
those systems but still remains
attractive and attention grabbing for
human
evaluators that's an art form and we can
help you with that but the uh
the
one-on-one
interview preparation Career Mentoring
that type of thing is also extremely
important because that will help you
both in terms of looking where you want
to actually work but but also
being able to put your best foot forward
when you get face to face with the
different people because you're going to
go through several rounds of interviews
to get a job
technical evaluation rounds
off skill interviews team fit interviews
management
final interviews so each of those steps
you have different requirements for what
they're looking for from you and uh
getting coaching on how to present
yourself at each of those stages is very
important very valuable to you so with
that I think we are out of time for
other questions again my apologies for
the folks whose questions we could not
get to but um
going to ask one last polling question
of the audience
and
very straightforward
of the
folks who said about 88 88 percent of
you who said that you are interested
in
joining the program about when would you
like to do it they always say that if
this is something that is going to
change your career and your life in a
positive way sooner than later is always
better but
a personal decision so
I'd like to get a feel from the audience
for when you're interested in doing this
oh
show you the result here
so about a quarter of the audience is
interested in doing that immediately
which
if you want to email ask us at
simplylearn.net quickly so that you can
get into the
program
induction on the 9th this month uh some
people but another 20 percent said they
would like to do it within three months
again
good idea to email us now and get that
process started and for the people
looking to do it further down the road
uh we assure you will be here
with this program for
a long time to come and so when you are
ready to take that step uh we will be
ready to assist you with that so
at this point I would like to say thank
you very much to
I also like say thank you to shubham for
being here today and both of them
helping you to understand what this
program is how it works and what it will
provide to you
and most of all I want to thank everyone
who attended today uh to find out about
this program
and we hope that you will join us as a
simply learned learner
contact us and ask us at simplylearn.net
to get that process started
and with that that concludes our
webinar for today any final words from
you benay uh vinay or uh
let's do it thank you so much for
attention
thank you everyone uh and all the best
for you uh
future and this new enroll for this
program I hope you enjoy the learning
and get your dream job in the future
thank you
thanks sister thanks vinay and thanks
everybody for joining in all the very
best
thank you all right and that's the
webinar so we will see you hopefully in
our classes